Okay.
Today we're going to continue our discussion of cellular principles and lead
into kind of cell culture technology,
which will be the subject of the section meeting this afternoon.
So just remind you about the,
the sections and we've been reading a chapter five.
And,
um,
we talked,
uh,
last time about some of the basic,
um,
properties of cells.
They're basic architecture in what ways cells are the same,
in what ways sales from animals,
including humans,
a differ from a simpler microorganisms like bacteria.
And then we talked a little bit about the sort of,
um,
physics of what holds cells together,
uh,
to form a collection of cells of tissue and to make up the structure of our
body.
And today we want to talk in more detail about the question of how can cells if
they're the same and they have the same kind of construction and they all
contain the same genetic material,
how can they develop into a multicellular organism that has cells that dipper so
greatly in function?
Uh,
the defer as much as the cells in our brain,
a differ from the cells of our skin or our liver or our blood.
And what are the sort of basic principles that lead to these differences between
cells.
And so to start out,
I'm gonna go back to the thinking about developmental little bit embryonic
development and,
uh,
show you a picture here.
And so this is a picture of the female reproductive tract.
This is the uterus down here,
sort of half of it is shown with the uterine wall,
the fallopian tubes and the ovaries.
And you know that the ovary produces an egg,
an egg and an egg is an example of a,
uh,
a germ cell has only half of the deployed chromosomal content that most of the
cells,
which are called somatic cells in our body have.
So germline cells,
sperm and egg,
are produced by the process of Meiosis.
And that's re reviewed in the book where it's a,
it's a special kind of cell division that results in the reduction of chromosome
number from two copies of each chromosome down to one copy of each chromosome,
right?
The other,
uh,
germline cell is the sperm cell.
And so fertilization of these to where these two selves join occurs in the
distal part of the Fallopian Tube.
And the result of fertilization now is a new cell that is the union of the sperm
and the egg at called the Zygote.
And it contains the diploid number of chromosomes genes.
So one copy of the chromosome comes from the egg and one copy of each chromosome
comes from that sperm.
So this is this,
this you know about.
So this one sell this one fertilized cell,
which is unique because it's the,
it's chromosome contains the combination of the sperm and the egg develops into
an embryo and then on birth develops into a,
into a human.
And each of us has something like 10 to the 14th cells.
And we talked about last time that that part of the process of going from this
single cell to multicellular,
many celled organisms like we are,
is cell division.
The cell divides and divides and divides,
uh,
many,
many times.
And that's one of the signature events of embryogenesis until we have many,
many cells that make up our bodies.
But in that process,
cells become different in ways that appear to be highly organized,
right?
We have,
uh,
tissues like the brain,
which are assembled to do functions that are different from any other groups of
cells in the body,
right?
And they work in concert and they all have similarities.
The same with all of our other organs.
So how does that happen?
Well,
that it really happens throughout development and it happens from the first
stages.
In fact,
there are differences that can be detected upon the first cell division where
the Zygote divides through the process of my ptosis,
and we talked about my tosas last time,
it's described more completely in the chapter where two cells are formed from
one.
Now these cells have some differences.
If you could look at these cells,
you could find differences between them.
There are chemical differences in the,
in the content of each of these cells.
Because if my ptosis occurs,
the way that it's supposed to,
the DNA that's in each of these cells is the same.
Right.
That's one of the properties of,
of my tosas that the DNA gets completely duplicated.
Um,
during the s phase,
during DNA synthesis phase.
But how,
how could these cells be different than if they contain the same DNA?
What's a physical mechanism that could lead to differences between these two
cells at this very early stage of development?
Any ideas
if,
if the DNA is synthesized exactly correctly.
So each one gets,
okay,
the right copies of DNA,
what other differences could there be?
Okay.
The size of the cells could be different.
Maybe my toast.
This is asymmetrical in some way so that one of the sales ends up being bigger
than the other.
And how could size effect
affect the life of the cell?
Yeah,
different amount of metabolic activity because one has a greater volume of
cytoplasm than the other,
for example.
And so the,
the,
these are exactly the right kinds of ideas.
There could be differences in the,
in the physics of,
of,
of cell division.
This process of separating into two cells such that even though they both have
the same chromosomes,
they both have the same DNA content,
maybe one of the cells in traps,
something that's different than the other cells.
All right?
And that difference could have been generated during the process of
fertilization,
right?
The sperm say this is the,
this is the one sperm cell that's able to inject its DNA into the egg.
Well then this cell has a polarity.
Now the top is different from the bottom because the sperm came in this side
physically and not the other side.
I remember that these cells are relatively large compared to bacteria.
And so diffusion doesn't occur very quickly over this length scale.
So,
uh,
in the time it takes for one cell division to occur,
it could be that this cell in traps a different chemical composition of the
cytoplasm,
then this and traps.
And that's a well known concept.
So the only important thing to realize about that is that these differences
start to occur very early in development.
And once you have a difference that occurs,
two cells are difference.
Those differences can propagate as the cells continue to divide.
So what's shown in,
uh,
in this diagram is the progress of the developing embryo.
As it travels in time down the Fallopian tube.
Uh,
there's one division here shows it at the 16 sales stage.
And then here in this transformation as it goes from 16 cells to more like 64
cells,
uh,
there's a change in sort of the shape of the overall embryo as well.
It's no longer just a around spiritual mass of cells,
but it has some structure.
There's a cluster of cells here.
There's,
uh,
a,
sheet of cells that forms an outer lining.
And what is most noticeable is this cavity,
this fluid filled cavity,
which begins to develop,
well,
this,
this stage of development is called the blastocyst.
Okay.
And it's at this stage late in this blastocyst stage that the developing embryo
implants in the uterine and,
uh,
and there begins to form an interface with the mother so that it can be
nourished during further development.
The cells of this surrounding sheet,
okay
have become different in some way and they develop into the placenta.
And the extra embryonic tissues.
The cells of this cluster inside next to the fluid filled cavity is that region
of the blastocyst called the inner cell mass.
And it's this group of cells,
this subset of cells from the developing embryo that become the embryo that
become the organism,
it become the human.
So we're going to talk as we go through a about the concept of stem cells and
how stem cells are related to development and what's so special about stem
cells.
And we're going to talk about different kinds of stem cells.
And one of the dip differences in stem cell populations that you will hear about
is you hear about embryonic stem cells and you hear about adult stem cells.
And those are obvious what the differences are.
Embryonic stem cells are derived from embryos and it's this,
it sells in this region here,
this inner cell mass,
uh,
that that's the source of embryonic stem cells.
All right,
sales from the inner cell mass here,
adult stem cells are acquired in some fashion from an adult organism.
So during development.
Now this blastocyst has become implanted these cells allowing the outside form,
the interface,
the placenta where the maternal blood circulation meets the embryonic
circulation and nutrients are passed back and forth that way in a very highly
regulated and important way.
And this inner cell mass develops into the embryo,
which this here shown it a later stage is beginning to be clear that it's
becoming an organism that looks like us,
right?
There's a,
there's a region that looks like a head and a region that looks more like the
tail.
And you can see this region here is going to develop into uh,
one of the upper limbs.
The arms here and the back is different from the front.
The spinal cord is developing in the back,
whereas the structures that become our intestinal tract is developing on the
other surface,
right?
So different kinds of polarity form,
There's a,
there's a head and there's a tail,
there's a back,
there's a front,
there's a left side and there's a right side.
And this is one of the kinds of differences that develop,
that that happens during development and cells somehow know where they are
within this,
uh,
developing asymmetrical organism.
How
does that happen?
It happens through a very,
uh,
a very,
um,
regulated,
coordinated slow process of what is called differentiation.
So cells move from a state of limited differentiation to a state of more
differentiation.
So the Zygote or this fertilized egg is a completely undifferentiated cell,
and we'll talk about another word for this later,
but it's a cell that's going to give rise to all the cells of our body,
right?
As division happens and the,
and the developing organism acquires more and more cells,
individual cells become differentiated,
they become more and more like their final mature form.
So cells that are within the region that becomes the nervous system become less
like the Zygote and more like the cells of our brain neurons and glial and cells
of the mature brain in the same way,
cells that form the limb become more like muscle cells or skin cells or the
structures that become the limb.
Well,
that process occurs in a series of steps and one of those kinds of steps is
shown here.
And in this diagram shows what I simply labeled as a stem cell.
So I'm not referring to any particular kind of stem cell now,
but just a cell that has the stem cell character.
And what does that mean to have the stem cell character?
It means that if I took this cell and isolated and watched it,
I noticed that it had a couple of characteristics.
One is that it's capable of something called asymmetrical division.
And we,
we talked about division last time we talked about the uh,
the um,
parents cell forming two identical daughter cells and an AME set metrical
division is not like that.
It's when a parent self forms two cells that are different in some way.
And that difference has functional consequences for the daughter cells in that
one of the daughter's cell becomes what's called here,
a committed progeneter cell.
It's no longer a stem cell,
but it's a progenitor cell and a progenitor cell.
The definition,
it just means it can generate the cells that are typical of that tissue or that
Oregon,
right?
So it's capable of becoming this mature classes of cells.
We'll talk more about this in the context of the brain,
but if we were talking about a stem cell in the brain,
then the result of this asymmetrical division would be a committed progeneter
cell that's capable of forming cells that are the cell types found in the brain
and not cells that are the cell types found in the liver or the kidney or the
spleen or muscle,
right?
So one result of this asymmetrical division is a committed progeneter cell.
The other result is a cell that's very similar,
but it is very similar to the progeneter cell,
but it's exactly the stem cell,
right?
So this stem cell division leads to another stem cell as well as a committed
progeneter cell.
Now,
the differences here may be subtle in terms of chemical composition or if you
put these cells under a microscope and look at their analysis.
But in terms of function,
they're very important because this,
this stem cell which has produced,
goes back into the population of stem cells and is able to repeat this process
to form new committed progeneter cells and to form new stem cells.
And that's important because one of the attributes of stem cells is that they
remain at their site and capable of reproducing themselves,
right?
And this process is called self renewal.
So that's one important process of property of stem cells that they're capable
of self renewal.
And the other one is a committed progeneter cell that now somehow has been
changed in such a way that it's going to mature and develop into,
uh,
into non stem cells are the cells that make up our body somatic cells.
Now what could these differences be?
They're not chromosomal differences,
right?
Cause this is the ordinary process of my tosas.
And so presumably these two cells have exactly the same DNA content,
but something's been passed on to this one that wasn't there.
And this is one of the very important areas that still is not completely
understood in stem cell biology.
What is the difference that's generated during an asymmetric cell division?
Uh,
there are types of changes that are known.
Some of them are changes in the,
not the sequence of DNA,
not the sequence of nucleotides in the DNA,
but,
but the chemistry of DNA around that,
the way that it's packed into a nucleus.
And so the access that is cell has to certain kinds of genes or chemical
modifications of DNA,
not chemical modifications that change the base pairs.
That would be a mutation,
right?
That can happen,
but that's abnormal,
right?
But changes in maybe the chemistry of the backbone that holds the nucleotides
together.
In some cases,
that backbone gets methylated and those regions of the DNA that are methylated
get treated differently by the cell,
then unmethylated regions.
So you go on and you study a developmental biology or molecular biology.
It learn more about these things for our purpose.
Just these are the kinds of changes that can happen.
Or it can be the kind of change we talked about before,
where during division there are some chemicals that are trapped in one cell and
not in the other.
Right?
And that could lead to a difference we already talked about or it could be not
having to do with the cells themselves,
but maybe the environment that the self finds itself in.
We talked last time about extra cellular matrix and this and this complex,
uh,
protein,
carbohydrate gel that surrounds all cells.
Well,
cell division takes place within an organism.
All right,
we'll talk in a minute about stem cells that are involved in generation of blood
and they,
they develop and they live in the bone marrow.
Well,
what if this division takes place in an environment where there's one kind of
extra cellular matrix here and another kind of extracellular matrix here.
Then this cell is going to experience something different from this cell.
And it could be those differences that they experienced in their extra sailor
environment that lead to their choice to either self renew or to become
committed.
Okay?
Uh,
so that's asymmetrical division and that's a property of stem cells.
The other property is that these committed progeneter cells that are formed can,
can,
uh,
can turn into something,
can turn into more mature cell types.
And that process of maturation is called differentiation.
Okay.
And,
um,
talk more about that and I've already said something about that.
Um,
so
yeah,
a capability for asymmetric division and the production of cells that become
differentiated more mature cells,
those are key properties of stem cells.
Okay.
Another concept that's important in thinking about stem cells is potential
and the potential refers to what it sounds like.
What potential does this committed progeneter cell have?
What potential does this stem cell have?
But one way to think about it is that upon this first division,
this asymmetric division,
this committed progeneter cell has lost some potential.
It's no longer capable of self renewal to form another stem cell.
It's gone down a path towards maturation that's very difficult to go back up.
So there's a loss of potential in this division,
this,
this stem cell,
which is reproduced,
still has the potential to undergo asymmetric division,
but this one does not.
And one sort of,
it might be kind of simple minded,
but one to think about potential is,
um,
with the kind of potential that we all experience as we develop from newborns to
adults,
right?
That a newborn child has lots of different potential,
It doesn't have every potential,
it's a boy or a girl.
It's not going to go back,
right?
But it has lots of potential and that eventually when it becomes an adult,
it could become a cellist or a biologist or an auto mechanic or a biomedical
engineer,
right?
All those potentials are still there.
As you develop,
as you're educated,
you,
um,
you retain all those potentials for a certain point and then you make choices
and you lose some of those potentials.
I'm unlikely to become a concert cellist at this point.
It's not impossible,
but it's pretty unlikely,
right?
So I've probably lost my potential to be,
uh,
to be,
an outstanding cellist.
Right?
You all could still do that if you decide to,
but,
um,
but it's going to be harder for you than if you would've started when you were
10.
Right?
And so you're losing some potential around long the way you're in the process of
becoming more mature and more differentiated and you're losing potential.
At the same time.
The same thing with these cells here as the cells undergo continual divisions,
they're changing in ways that make them more mature,
that make them more like the mature cells of the nervous system.
For example,
if that's where they end up being a but they're losing potential as they go
through that differentiation process.
Now,
one of the great hopes of,
of modern biology is that we can figure out how to reverse that process in
cells,
how we could take cells that are differentiated to some extent and make them d
differentiate to go back in the process of,
of differentiation so that they gain more potential.
And why would that be useful?
Will be useful.
Because if I could take cells from the skin,
find stem cells in the skin,
and then d differentiate them so that they were now capable of becoming liver or
brain or things that they're not going to become in their normal site,
then that could be a very powerful tool for medicine.
Right?
Uh,
but so far our ability to d differentiate cells or find out how to do that as
limited,
it just makes sense.
So what,
what is actually changing during this process of differentiation?
What's,
what's the difference between this cell,
which I call a committed progeneter cell and its offspring and the offspring of
that offspring?
It goes,
going through this process of amplifying divisions.
Every division increasing the number of cells by a factor of two.
Uh,
and these sales becoming more differentiated around the way I've shown the
differences here in terms of shape.
These are shaped like octagon and these are shaped like squares.
But if I looked at these cells,
what would I find that's really different about them?
What's different from a,
from an immature cell and a mature cell?
Well,
it's not the,
it's not the DNA,
right?
They all have the same DNA.
There might be these what are called epigenetic differences that I mentioned
changes in the structure around DNA.
And those changes lead to differences in which fraction of the total genes in
the chromosomes are being expressed by a particular cell.
And this is what makes cells different,
right?
That the number and quantity of the genes that they express.
So out of all the genes that are on the human genome,
which fraction is this particular cell using?
Which fraction is expressing,
determines what proteins are present in the cell,
determines what work or what activities the cell can engage in.
All right,
so what's changing along here is the,
what's changing along this pathway is the expression pattern of genes in a,
in cells.
And make this a little bit more explicit by talking about the process of
hematopoiesis and hematopoiesis is the process of generating new blood cells.
Have Matto,
uh,
means uh,
blood and pollicis means generation or formation.
And uh,
you know,
probably that within your bone marrow there's,
there's a populations of cells,
there are different kinds of cells within the bone marrow.
And uh,
some of them have the capability of becoming red blood cells which carry oxygen
in the blood.
Some of them have the capability of becoming white blood cells or leukocytes,
of which there are many different subsets,
some are called neutrophils,
and those are responsible for,
uh,
for um,
um,
fighting infection.
Uh,
some are called lymphocytes,
B lymphocytes,
t lymphocytes.
We're going to talk about those in more detail in a couple of weeks when we talk
about the immune system because these are the cells that that perform and
regulate the functions of our immune system that protects us from a disease and
some of form what are called mega carrier sites,
which become platelets,
which are responsible for uh,
for clotting,
for forming a barrier if you're a circulatory system gets injured,
right?
So you don't bleed.
All these sales come from the bone marrow and biologists have traced the
formation of these cells in great detail.
In fact,
of all the,
of all the systems of cellular differentiation that are known in our bodies,
probably hematopoiesis is the best known and it was the first place where the
concept of stem cells was developed in that if one looks carefully,
one confined immature cells in the bone marrow.
And if you isolate those immature cells,
some of them are less mature than others,
some of them have more potential than others.
For example,
if by isolated this one called the myeloid cell,
it's capable of forming red blood cells,
mega carrier sites and neutrophils.
It's capable of forming all these different cells,
but it's not capable of forming lymphocytes.
Another stem cell called the lymphoid stem cell is capable of forming,
forming the B and t lymphocytes.
And so through many decades of study,
biologists have teased out certain populations of cells within the bone marrow
that are capable of,
of reproducing subsets of cells,
right.
Um,
now
in the process of doing that,
they found some very rare stem cells that are called plurry.
Potent plurry just means many potencies pluripotent stem cells that are capable
of self renewal to generate themselves and are capable of dividing into both
myeloid and lymphoid progenitor cells.
Okay.
So this is an example of that asymmetric division.
This pluripotent stem cell is able to self renew and it's April of,
of generating,
um,
committed progenitors of either the myeloid or the lymphoid lineage.
Yeah.
And so if I got these two cells,
they would be less,
they would have less potential than these.
Why is it so hard to find stem cells?
I mentioned that this is a process has taken many decades and lots of people
studying.
Why has it been so hard and why does it continue to be difficult to identify
these,
uh,
these pluripotent cells within tissues?
Well,
one reason is that they're present in very small numbers.
All right?
And so have a million cells in the bone marrow.
There might only be one of these,
you know,
this might be one in 100 billion or something like that.
Don't write down the numbers.
I'm just using that for,
um,
for illustration that these cells are rare and so it's been hard to identify
them.
That's part of it.
The other part of it is how do you identify them?
How do I know when I've got this one or this one in this diagram I'm showing
you?
It's easy to tell because some are yellow and some are pink and some are blue.
But that's not the way they come out of the bone marrow.
Right?
They're not,
they're not colored coded.
And so how do you find them?
How do you think,
what Wa,
if you were searching for,
uh,
for unique populations of cells,
the bone marrow,
what tools would you use to look for them?
How would you,
how would you search for these sales?
Well,
one way would be to isolate individual cells and culture them outside the body
and see what they become.
Now,
it'd be a very straightforward functional way to do it,
but you can imagine that that's,
uh,
that's very labor intensive because you've got to separate each individual cell
and you've got to nurture it and then keep track and study what it becomes.
And that turns out to be one really important way that they do it.
The other way that they define or find stem cells is that over the years of
studying them,
we've begun to recognize some of the proteins,
the specific proteins that are produced by these characteristics cells.
So this cell here,
which is indicated green,
is different than this cell.
That's that,
that's,
that's colored red.
And the difference,
the real difference is in what genes it's expressing of it,
of the total number of genes in the human genome.
And therefore if it's expressing these unique,
this unique set of genes,
if I could find the unique set of proteins that correspond to those jeans,
I could define kind of chemically what the cell is and it it,
it turns out that one of the places that's been very fruitful for to look for
proteins that differ between cell populations is on the surface of the cell.
And we talked about the cell membrane,
the plasma membrane separating the inside from the outside.
And I mentioned a little bit that this membrane is not just lip it by layer,
but there's also proteins that are inserted into the membrane and these proteins
have functions that are essential,
that essential for life of the cell.
They transport molecules back and forth across the membrane and they also allow,
there are populations of proteins on the surface of each cell that allow it to
interact with its environment,
their receptors and uh,
cell adhesion receptors like I talked about last time,
the kinds of proteins that sit on the cell surface and form adhesion junctions
with neighboring cells.
That's one class of cells.
On the surface,
there are cell,
there are,
that's one class of proteins on the surface,
I'm sorry.
There are proteins that are responsible for receiving signals,
chemical signals.
There are proteins for example,
on the surface of some cells that bind insulin and respond to the presence of
insulin.
And we're going to talk more about these kinds of molecules on the surface.
Uh,
next week for now.
Just know that different kinds of cells,
one of the ways they're different is that they express different proteins and
the population of proteins on the surface of different cells is different.
And so we've learned how to identify and categorize and catalog sells according
to the composition of proteins on the surface.
And those proteins that distinguish a seller often called marker proteins.
Yeah,
they're given names.
And so,
and we're able to often the names are confusing.
If you look in the literature,
you'll find uh,
proteins that are called CD 44,
CD three.
These are differentiation.
Cluster differentiation antigens is what CD stands for,
but it really means a particular protein which is present on this cell but not
on that cell.
And so I can use the presence of those to identify,
to identify,
um,
cell populations.
Right?
So one reason it's been harder to identify stem cells is that they're so rare.
The other reason is that it's hard to identify the characteristics of them.
And it's taken many years to work this out.
And in the,
in the,
um,
uh,
amount of poetic system,
it's the most well known.
In fact,
it's so well known now that we've identified proteins that stimulate the
development of cells along certain pathways.
And I talked about one of them a couple of weeks ago.
The protein Hipo,
a wreath throw poet called,
uh,
called Hipo is a naturally occurring protein that is in the bone marrow.
And it,
it stimulates the,
uh,
the development of red blood cells.
And so it stimulates these myeloid cells to develop along this pathway.
Yeah,
right.
It's a protein that's produced by other cells in the body.
And when it's enriched in a certain area,
it stimulates more production of,
of,
uh,
red blood cells.
And because we've learned about that biology,
we've been able to make a retro poet and outside the body and use it as a drug
so it can be used given to people,
uh,
to,
who have certain kinds of anemia to stimulate blood cell production in a
specific kind of way.
And there's lots of these so called signaling proteins that have been identified
now.
And these signaling proteins play important roles in determining,
uh,
how many cells differentiate down particular pathways.
And they turned out also to be a very useful for treating diseases of those
pathways.
Okay.
Well the um,
this,
um,
plurry potent.
Okay.
Stem cell from bone marrow is an example of a stem cell,
an adult stem cell,
a stem cell that could be identified from the blood
different than the embryonic stem cell we talked about before.
So it's an example of an adult stem cell.
It's also an example of a tissue specific stem cell.
Those stem cells from the blood are capable of becoming all those cells in the
blood.
They're not capable of becoming other kinds of sales in general.
Now you'll,
you'll hear reports in the literature.
You'll look in the newspaper,
you'll hear about,
uh,
about scientists that have found ways to,
trans differentiate cells that is moved them from one pathway to the other
defined stem cells that they can move from one kind of pathway to another.
And that's been,
uh,
looking at blood stem cells has been a very fruitful way to look for that.
So,
so there are some ways that you can take stem cells that normally would only
produce blood cells and maintain them in culture,
expose them to certain regimens of chemicals,
do certain manipulations on these cells and they become capable of producing
liver,
for example,
or brain or muscle.
And that's a lot of the literature of stem cells that you'll read about taking a
particular source of stem cell and nurturing it in such a way that it gains
potentials that it didn't have necessarily when it was in the body or exploiting
those potentials that it wouldn't necessarily express.
Right.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a lot of what a stem cell biology is like.
It is about this diagram here sort of
allows me to walk you through some of the terminology of this stem cell
development and talk about these concepts again in the context of a specific
tissue site.
In this case,
it's the nervous system.
And so we started the discussion talking about the Zygote or the fertilized egg.
There's only one source for that.
Yeah,
right?
There's only one source of that fertilized egg.
It's,
um,
it's not self renewing in that division of the Zygote results in two daughter
cells that are no longer,
you know,
the Zygote anymore.
They're down some pathway.
Uh,
but it's,
uh,
it,
one way of referring to this cell is in terms of its potential and the Zygote
obviously has the potential of becoming all the cells of our body.
That's where they all come from.
They all come from the Zygote.
And so the word for that is toady potent,
totally potent.
It has the capability of becoming any kind of cell within the body.
In fact,
that's what it does.
Further down the line.
For example,
in the blastocyst I talked about before,
we could obtain cells from this inner cell mass or this cluster of cells that
becomes the embryo and those are called embryonic stem cells.
They are self renewing and they are plurry potent meaning they have many
potencies.
And that's why people are so excited about embryonic stem cells because
in nature they become all the cells of the body.
If we understood them well enough,
we could potentially make any particular kind of cell in the body from those,
uh,
from those pluripotent cells.
They're controversial I think for obvious reasons because you have to sacrifice
that an embryo in order to,
in order to get them.
Um,
further down this line here,
um,
are embryonic or let's say adult brain stem cells.
So these are,
these are cells that I,
that were obtained either from a more developed embryo past the blastocyst
stage,
for example,
that embryo that I showed on one of the first slides where there's clearly a
head region and a tail region and now I isolated these cells may be from the
head region of the embryo,
the region.
That's going to develop into the brain.
So that would be a good place to look.
If you wanted cells that we're going to develop into the brain,
they're capable of self renewal.
They're not quite as potent as the cells from earlier because they've now
differentiated somewhat.
So they might be capable of forming all the cells of the nervous system.
They might still have some potency to form other things that are similar to the
nervous system.
Maybe they could make skin right?
Maybe they could make,
uh,
other kinds of cells if you treated them the right way.
So they've lost some capabilities,
but not,
but not many.
And these are called multipotent stem cells.
Uh,
they still have broad potential and they're self renewing.
And so there's much interest in those,
easiest to find them in embryos,
but sometimes they can be found in adult organisms as well.
If you go to the right region of an adult brain,
you might be able to find cells like this,
but it's,
but it's more difficult.
And as we,
as we've found cells from adult organisms that seem to be multipotential and
studied them more carefully,
uh,
some of their potentials turn out to be lost.
They're not exactly the same.
Right?
And further down the line here,
if we looked in the adult brain or spinal cord in other regions,
we'd find committed progeneter cells.
These are cells that are committed to become a nervous,
I'm nervous tissue.
They might self renew,
they might not.
They have much more limited potential than before.
And you,
you're starting to see the pattern,
right?
As I moved further and further away from the embryo from less differentiated to
more differentiated from,
from nonspecific regions to more specific regions,
I'm getting cells that have,
that are easier to obtain because you can obtain them from adults sources,
right?
But their potential as stem cells is more limited,
There are a couple of tissues that are of particular interest to,
uh,
to scientists and clinicians now and uh,
and bone marrow is one of those,
there's a lot of interest in bone marrow and the stem cells that come from bone
marrow.
And a couple of reasons for this.
One is because we understand the bone marrow system so much better than we
understand all the other stem cell systems.
And the other is that it's possible to get stem cells from patients from bone
marrow.
You can collect bone marrow.
It's not a procedure that you would want to do.
I involves putting,
uh,
putting a needle,
a fairly large needle into usually the one of the pelvic bones and collecting
marrow from which is tissue that's deep inside those bones.
So it's not as easy as getting your blood drawn.
Uh,
if you give blood to the Red Cross for example.
But,
but it can be done very safely.
And wouldn't it be great if we could identify stem cells that were multipotent,
uh,
from that,
from that bone marrow because you could find them potentially four.
If I needed a treatment that could,
if I had some ailment that could be treated with stem cells,
then you could get my own,
I could get my own stem cells and use them.
Or maybe I could donate bone marrow and those stem cells could be given to other
people in the same way that blood can be given to other people by matching
right?
By matching and making sure that immunologically my cells were,
uh,
were compatible with you.
All right?
It's a lot of interest in that.
There's a lot of interest in obtaining stem cells from the blood of the
umbilical cord on birth.
And it turns out that blood within the umbilical cord is also a rich source of
stem cells.
And,
um,
and again,
specific to a particular patient.
So there are services now we don't know yet how to get those stem cells out of
cord blood and how to use them for therapies.
But it's reasonable to think that we might know about this in 30 years.
And so some parents now are choosing to save the cord blood,
have it frozen,
locked away somewhere,
just in case it's useful to their child later in life.
I'm not endorsing that,
I'm just saying that that's something that can be done now.
Um,
so I digressed a little from this diagram,
but I think you've gotten the picture that as I moved to more adult organisms,
as I move to more specific regions of the brain,
for example,
I can still find progenitor cells that have some potential,
but,
uh,
it's harder to find.
They're more limited numbers and in general,
um,
more difficult until eventually down this pathway you have fully differentiated
cells,
cells that are fully mature and performing the function of the mature Oregon.
And so the two largest populations of cells within the brain are neurons,
the ones that actually transmit electrical activity and responsible for,
uh,
the main,
functions we think of when we think of the brain and supporting cells called
glial cells,
which are responsible for sort of creating the right sort of environment for
neurons to function.
I wanted to talk about one last concept,
and this is one of the boxes from chapter five,
and you've already been using this,
uh,
using this in your homework,
but I just wanted to talk about one last concept and that has to do with cell
proliferation.
And we've been talking about,
uh,
about,
you know,
single-cell or some,
some,
some subset of sales and propagating them so that you get a larger population of
cells.
And of course this happens all the time in the body.
There are cells within your body that are always in the process of division and
forming new cells.
And sometimes this is for,
uh,
for a tissue where sales only have a finite lifetime.
The red blood cells that carry oxygen only live within your circulation for
about a month.
And so you have to continually be replacing cells that are dying.
So there are cells that are proliferating.
Cell proliferation is a huge issue in cell culture.
One of the main fund,
one of the main things that we use cell culture or,
or,
uh,
maintenance of cells outside the body for is to make more copies of cells.
One of the purposes of cell culture is to make many,
many more cells under controlled conditions where I can understand what those
cells are.
And so in general,
when cells are proliferating,
they're,
uh,
they're dividing and they're dividing at a regular rate.
And what that means is that one way to describe that mathematically is shown
here.
If x is the number of cells,
then the rate of change of x Dxdt the rate of change of the cell population,
how fast division has taken is proportional to the number of cells to have right
in.
This makes sense,
right?
That the,
the,
the rate at which the cell population is growing,
the derivative DXDT is proportional to the number of sales I have.
The more sales I have,
the faster they can grow,
right?
Fewer cells grows more slowly.
And this is an example of an exponential growth process
and you're familiar with processes like these,
but if you solve this differential equation,
which you don't need to do for the course,
but I showed here,
some of you will understand immediately where this comes from.
That means that the number of sales I have at any particular time is equal to
the number of cells that I have at some starting time times e to the power mew
here.
Um,
where,
and it should be mew t looks like there's a Typo in the book.
Yeah.
You just can't see it here.
Maybe,
um,
each of the mew tea or this constant times time and this constant mew,
which is the proportionality constant between the number of cells and the rate
of growth is a constant that characterizes how fast a cell population is
growing.
Some will be growing very rapidly,
some will be growing less rapidly.
And what this,
what this equation shows you here is how to relate that,
uh,
that growth constant mew or that rate of growth to the doubling time of cells.
How long does it take for the population of sales to double?
And one of the interesting properties of cells that are an exponential growth is
that the time to increase the,
to increase the cell number by a factor of two is always the same.
Right?
And that makes sense.
If you think about this process of cell multiplication that I have one cell,
it becomes two cells.
In a minute it could become four cells and another minute it can become eight
cells in another minute.
Right?
And that's all that this,
uh,
that this,
um,
set of equations is representing
questions about that.
Good.
I'll see you in section this afternoon.